well just in the last 15 minutes or so
things have changed slightly this
morning things are very quiet very
subdued very peaceful they were doing
yoga in the middle of Oxford Circus
more and more numbers started arriving
by 10 o'clock or so and as I said within
the last 15 minutes things have shifted
slyly because I estimate maybe sort of
300 or so police officers have just
arrived I'm going to step out the way so
you can have a better look they've
essentially surrounded this big pink
boat which is essentially the extinction
rebellion iconic boat that's been
sitting in the middle of Oxford Circus
for the last five days it's worth saying
that also in the last hour or so the
actress Emma Thompson who's a a big
supporter of the movement has arrived
she addressed crowds here you can see
her there on the live shot a couple of
officers - arriving with carabiners
perhaps indicating that they might try
and get up and try and get people safely
off that boat I'm underneath you can see
there are people chained to it they say
they're refusing to move until the
government address their demands and I
interviewed Emma Thompson earlier this
is what she had to say about the
protests and the climate change threat
to me
I've been with Greenpeace to the Arctic
twice I've stood on the on the bear
glaciers I've seen the plastic in the
oceans I've seen evidence for myself and
I really do care about my children and
my grandchildren enough to want to be
here today to stand next to the next
generation who are so inspiring who so
understand the problem it's as though
we've just been going around well not me
actually where I've been banging on
about it for years but and so have many
many people but I really do feel like I
even describe the level of hypocrisy
from our government
so hello man that's all happening behind
you in Oxford Circus what's the latest
on Heathrow where there hasn't been
quite the same turnout from extinction
rebellion produce yeah well there were
big concerns that Heathrow would be
brought to a standstill today the
protests are saying yesterday they're
going to up the ante I blocked that
airport because air travel is so
damaging to the environment really what
ended up happening is only about 20
young people turning up blocked a road
for a very short period of time and then
moved off not a single flight affected
which of course a big relief for the
500,000 or so people who might have been
looking to travel this back holiday
weekend but really here this feels like
this is where the police attention is so
far the the tactic has been quite
softly-softly police arriving picking
off arresting protesters one by one and
all know those you know numbers of those
arrested exceeding 600 in the context of
the thousands of people who have been
here over the last five days and other
sites across London that's really not
that manic very many and indeed the
process of arresting very very resource
and time intensive protesters adopting a
tactic where they're lying on the ground
which means it's taking four officers at
least to arrest each individual and they
also don't have the space or the
resource within custody to hold them for
very long so as I said you know police
and on other days have arrived and
started arresting pretty quickly
they've been here 15 minutes also
standing blocking some of the key
locations but at the moment they haven't
made a move so we will see what happens
and what develops in the coming minutes
and hours